no one's getting past me yes they are
because it's estimated that between 27
and 40% of all undocumented immigrants
in America came here on planes 27 to 40%
of our people coming on planes it goes
on to say overstaying their visas got it
have you done the math yet that means
that minimum sixty percent of the
illegal immigration doesn't occur from
planes and visas
Adam ruins everything as a show I've
actually really liked Adam ruins
everything I'm glad a few things have
taken some sort of I guess libertarian
stances but generally speaking it's it's
pretty informative this is one where
they were completely wrong if you're
listening to it it could sound plausible
what he says but I've got some
information here that might just smack
you over that so let's roll the first
clip building a wall would actually
increase the number of illegal
immigrants in America know what how
could it possibly here I'll show you
first off that is not true let me tell
you something here a book that I
recommend it's up on my page stolen
sovereignty how to stop unelected judges
from transferring America Daniel
Horowitz he talks about illegal
immigration quite a bit in a way that is
is very informative and very
enlightening no one's getting past me
yes they are
because estimated that between 27 and
40% of all undocumented immigrants in
America came here on planes I forgot
about planes and that's just said so
flippantly right Oh
building a wall because 27 to 40 percent
of the our people come in on planes it
goes on to say overstaying their visas
got it
have you done the math yet that means
that minimum 60 percent of the illegal
immigration doesn't occur from planes
and visas someone call the dropsies
seventy three percent at least not
planes and visas so here's the deal does
it mean that a wall will fix everything
no one's saying that but if you could
have some sort of an effect on let's use
the most conservative figure 60% of
illegal immigration by his own admission
how is that not significant enough to
build a wall Joe Rogan talks about this
if you had a ham sandwich there was 60%
crap and 40% ham you'd probably want do
something about the crap it's still 60%
crap so the number there right off the
bat most hotdogs the percentage is true
the number right there right off the bat
should concern you
it debunks the entire argument if you
believe that even curbing that pesky
little 60 to 70% is worthwhile you don't
even need to watch the rest of the video
I do I assume many of you do let's
assume you say you know what I'll
of them 60 to 70% it would easily be one
of the single most expensive pieces of
infrastructure in American history
costing as much as 20 Hoover dams or
NASA's entire annual budget just an
annual budget why one annual budget this
is supposed to turn us off
I say we turned ass off for you just
turn this off just the rock out a year
like the UN will do with the Internet
yep throttle it a little bit and just
start putting up the wall it is on
that's not that expensive particularly
when you look at the economic
ramifications positive ones when you
stop the illegal immigration next clip
even by your estimate of visa overstays
the wall would still stop about half of
America's 11 million illegal immigrants
no it wouldn't because of a little
something called circular flow here I'll
show you
for decades immigration to the US was a
circular flow it would come work for a
bit and then after they were done to go
home to their families that's morally
reprehensible that was never what
America was intended to be it wasn't
intended to be a revolving door so
people could come in abuse a system and
leave you don't come to a country to
drain from the country to send to other
countries that's not how a country works
that's not being ethnocentric that's not
being xenophobic that's called having a
country okay the revolving door they
talk about people coming in revolving
door to work and send back benefits hey
that's not right you don't get to do
that you move here legally period right
we've already covered that but the
revolving door for work is very
different from a revolving door for
entitlements people are going through
the revolving door right now and not
paying for health care and not paying
taxes and getting all of the social
benefits the benefits from the social
safety net from hardworking Americans
that's the right it's never supposed to
be a revolving door and it's worse now
because a lot of illegal immigrants
aren't really coming here to work not
all of them but many of them are coming
here and they're taking more than
they're given sound like working in New
York and then living in New Jersey no
it's a little bit different next clip
it's counterintuitive but building a
wall wouldn't stop people from coming in
it would actually stop them from going
back
the number of illegal border crossings
is actually at an all-time low no that's
not sure I have it up right here
Washington Examiner illegal border
crossings by children families are
surging again we'll put the fiscal year
of 2016 on par with 2014 there's a chart
for you here's why listen at a certain
point of course immigration is going to
start slowing down because Mexico has
dumped 1/10 1/10 10% of its population
have moved the united states so at a
certain point you're going to hit a
critical mass of how many people can
leave their crappy country to a better
country the United States 10 percent 12
maybe it'll go back to 8 it'll hover
around there now here's why this chart
occurred because of all actually the
deportations as they've plummeted more
people have been coming back in and now
we're facing the surge that we had in
2014 so the inverse is true of what
they've said as deportations have
plummeted as Barack Obama tried to act
and really what's happened as people are
being treated more humanely they would
lope theirs now all of a sudden we see
this you can see this sort of like a fat
caterpillar in the graph we have a
problem with the illegal immigration
again of course and the problems that
come with that draining on the system
the problem of the social safety net of
fiscal responsibility do we have more
clips oh my god Adam you're right the
wall isn't the answer
good millions of people are already here
we need to deport them yes deportation
is the answer no and of course it's
racist to deport people who've broken
the law and come here illegally
again it's here's that's that that's
that sleight of hand it starts off with
will it would only help with maybe half
maybe sixty seventy three percent and so
if you just do that you don't even think
about it you're thinking you heard 10%
you go well then that's silly why would
we spend the whole NASA budget to stop
ten percent no you're spending actually
a very reasonable budget and we can get
Mexico to pay for at least a portion of
it if you look at the actual plans and
tariffs and what you can do with the
transfer of money Donald Trump isn't
completely unrealistic to get them to
pay for a portion of it you can pay for
that it's realistic and that would deal
with sixty to seventy something percent
of illegal immigration but if you don't
understand what you're hearing you go
along with them down that logic trail
and you follow them a false stat false
to
false idea false narrative to the point
where deportation is racist and you get
to call Donald Trump or people like us
racist people like me who come from
legal immigrants like my mom who learned
the language who pay taxes who are
active contributing citizens this idea
that we don't take in enough legal
immigrants it's it's just not true it's
not even close
fifty percent of all immigrants since
1965 have come from Latin America
twenty-nine from Mexico alone that's not
even taking into account people who come
here legally who overstay visas more
people have come to the United States
from Mexico than any other country in
our modern history okay over the past
forty four years they have these numbers
six point six five million people have
emigrated legally to the United States
compared to the previous record world
who are a world record holder Italy four
point five million it's not even close
this idea that we don't take enough
Mexicans in legally that it's incredibly
hard more legal people have come to the
United States from Mexico by an
unbelievable margin it can be done it's
been done from Mexico more than any
other country and of course it's been
done by plenty of other countries so
building a wall beefing up the security
all you have to decide is it worth it to
spend a relatively small amount to stop
60 to 70 percent of illegal immigration
I don't know I leave that to you
hey Jarrod's laughing this video is
taken from the full weekly podcast
louder with Crowder subscribe by
clicking it Jarrod's laughing because
he's act he just got shot the loss of
blood is making him delirious who shot
him guilty